this is just another
one of those special moments in in my
career
um it's great obviously fodder for media
outlets there's just so many great
storylines and there always are i mean
that's the nfl there's so many great uh
great people and great story to talk
about obviously tommy's had an amazing
career
you know his legacy is
one of so many wins and so many
accomplishments
and i've been a fan of his for a long
time and enjoyed the few times and
gotten to play
i remember when i heard the news about
him coming to the nfc i thought this was
a real possibility
and i'm excited about the opportunity to
play against him one more time
brady together in the postseason for the
first time ever
it felt inevitable at some point a
decade ago that the packers and the
patriots would get together in the super
bowl then it would
have happened what six years ago but
for that screwy comeback by the seattle
seahawks in the nfc
championship game i mean the packers had
it won there were so many things you
could point to
i'd still be tormented by that if i was
a packers fan six years later
the way that they had that game in their
clutches and it would have been
tom brady versus aaron rodgers then but
the next best thing is tom brady versus
aaron rodgers now
and you throw in the weather shireen
they're calling for snow
it's going to be cold tom brady is
familiar
with both yesterday was the the 19th
anniversary
of the tuck roll game i i i just
i i i wonder whether
the players who haven't played in the
cold
can truly appreciate it before
they actually experience it and if
things were normal right now and i were
the buccaneers
i'd get up there early and have a couple
of days practicing outside just to get
people
acclimated to what it feels like to try
to perform in those
circumstances yeah when i was in tampa
mike i remember
every single year every december i would
write that the bucks
are this record in under 45 degrees and
it was forever since they had won a game
and this is obviously a different
buccaneers team
but a lot of these players mike haven't
played into january
so they don't know what it's like they
don't know how cold it is they haven't
played at lambeau field in january when
the temperature is below 30 degrees and
they're still
training in tampa where it's warm we
know that but they do
have the one guy who's been really good
in the cold weather we know
tom brady and that's never stopped him
and it's not going to stop him this week
but i'm with you for some of these
players who haven't played in it
i absolutely take them there early and
get acclimated a little bit to cold
weather decide what you're going to wear
that's important what kind of cleats are
you going to wear
what kind of thing what are you going to
have underneath your jersey if anything
how are you going to prepare for this
game and
especially mentally i mean they've
talked they've all talked about that
it's a mental thing so get them ready
for it mentally beforehand
there were two great storylines about
the buccaneers early in their existence
there was an extended period of time
before they had a kickoff return for a
touchdown
years and years and years and it was 27
years
where they hadn't won a game when the
temperature at kickoff was below
40. they were oh and 21. it was december
of 2002 the year they won the super bowl
they were 11 and four the bears were
four and 11 they went to chicago for
that late season game in late december
and they got the win
for the first time ever the thermometer
below 40 at kickoff and the bucks get
the win well it's going to be a lot
lower than 40 on
sunday here's bruce arians talking about
how the weather
could or will be a factor when the bucks
and the packers get together on sunday
i don't really consider 28 degrees cold
i grew up in the north
we got a lot of guys that played in
green bay
and played from in colleges up north the
weather
the weather won't affect the ball game i
don't think at all
he's got the red chameleon thing going
on whatever shade of red he's wearing
that's the color of his
face can we pull that up his face was
pink the other day when he was wearing a
pink
shirt he's wearing red with the red
sunglasses on top
he is the exact color he is a chameleon
as long as the color is red shireen
he almost looks like santa claus there
just needs the full beard instead of the
partial beard there and he'd look just
like santa claus
hey 28 is cold it's been 28 ish
here the past few days like i took the
garbage out last night
it's cold and it takes a while to get
used to it
and you feel it you know that like a
little
knives in your lungs and now look in the
20s you can live with when it gets below
20 that's when it really becomes a
challenge but it affects your breathing
it affects your performance it affects
how you feel
and i think it's more of a factor we're
on the sideline trying to get warm when
you're moving around
it's a little bit easier but you know
i've been out and i've done things
physically in the cold before whether
it's playing football when you're a kid
or going out and running in the cold
it it you feel different you stiffen up
your body doesn't react the way that it
ordinarily does and i think that's going
to be a factor for both teams but the
more
used to it you are the easier it's going
to be to understand what's happening and
react to it
i saw a stat and i'm not sure if it's
just the postseason or
or all the time but under 28 degrees
brady six and two rogers seven and one
so they both had great success
in cold weather but again you know it
goes back to those bucks players who
have little playoff experience
and little experience playing in the
cold weather and i was there for that
bucks championship game when they beat
the eagles and it was
let me just tell you it was cold that
day veterans stadium they had
they had actually had the media outside
we weren't in the press box and it was
brutal but i can't imagine that ball
hitting your hands mike hitting your
arms how bad that must hurt
and especially if you're not used to it
oh yeah that football when it gets cold
my goodness especially a fairly new nfl
football that is properly inflated
that's a different story though hey
it's going to be cold here's hoping
that's right when they do the spot
checks if they do them at halftime they
understand pv
equals nrt it's not going to be 12.5
pounds per square inch after an hour and
a half
my god and we're up on the six year
anniversary
i think it's it's either happened or
it's coming whatever it is we're getting
close to the moment
where it will be six years since the
colts patriots game that brought us
deflategate i don't miss talking about
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports